yeah clarify which was like it was we
all went to CES in January we're all in
Vegas every year in January and we just
went around the room and just went what
phone do you use I saw that with you
yeah just what phone is in your pocket
right now take it out show us with phone
use iPhone after iPhone after iPhone and
there's a couple pixels in there but
every time you ask an iPhone person like
so why an iPhone and they're like man I
message FaceTime like that ecosystem is
real Luis seemed angry more people
weren't using pixels you know well there
was all thing about just whatever phone
there's a lot of people who do sponsored
videos well they'll talk about a phone
as if they use it but they don't and
that was one of the things that at CES
specifically that we kind of had a laugh
with at our studio because you would
think like if you watched everyone's
videos like oh everyone is using a
huawei everyone I guess while we had a
big budget for CES and they just paid a
lot bunch of people to make mate 10 Pro
videos and that's CES so if you if you
went into watching a video like what
phone is in everyone's pocket I think
you would just assume everyone's got a
wall way mate 10-4 oh and nobody did
that's dirty and then the other thing is
about Huawei I hate trashing Huawei but
I also kind of love thrashing wooly is
they have a lot of money to pay
celebrities to tweet ads for Wow way
basically gal gadot being one of them
right have you heard this story so she's
tweeted a bunch of Huawei ads and I
noticed that while she's a brand
ambassador for a while way tweeting ads
about how much she loves her Huawei
phone if you look in the details of the
tweet it's always via Twitter for iPhone
oh and it's like whatever she can use an
iPhone I don't care but I thought it was
funny so I just tweeted it it's very
funny it blew up and I had Huawei reach
out to me like how did you find this how
did you know where did you this is a is
this a mistake like could this be a like
has this ever malfunction I'm like no
this is that's how Twitter works like
you can see the data it's clearly an
iPhone and I thought that's hilarious as
my screenshot and so not only did gal
gadot pop
gal gadot the [ __ ] Wonder Woman lady
yeah Wonder Woman ah so Wonder Woman you
[ __ ] fake from an iPhone it's just
funny because look at the picture there
she blocked you not only get she blocked
me but Huawei since then has tweeted all
they deleted like her latest tweets and
reposted them from an Android phone and
she's tweeted from an Android phone ever
since I'll give a respect for that Wow
they probably told her you know lose all
that cash there's no way she's tweeting
like she has a team I get it but like
whoever was on her team tweeting from an
iPhone like the fact that she blocked
you those rows hilarious that's gross no
I didn't I think well I tagged her an
inch per I was just getting bashed by
like people going wow you're using an
edge like an iPhone why I think event it
was like a year later she unblocked me
it was really funny oh she unblocked on
blocked me
thanks young thanks well I've really
loved her as Wonder Woman and my friend
patty is actually directing that movie
nice directed the first one she's
directing the second one too so she says
gal is a great gal tell her gal I said
hi gal it's okay you got busted good
happen you're not alone
you're a hundred percent not alone